welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
please have on for the first time mike
posner the grammy-nominated singer
songwriter who just completed a walk
across America from New Jersey to this
state of California and the
grammy-nominated singer songwriter right
here with a by the way a new album keep
going that's been released earlier this
month with his new song nothing is wrong
which is a reflection of his walk good
to see you sir now I do I'm mandated
asked this question and I know that that
we normally do this anyway we sent a car
for you to come here correct that's
right you did not walk here to this do
no no no yes right man I walked enough I
said I want to make sure that we took
care of very good I don't think it was a
Lincoln MKZ
I was in the back extra so why did you
do what you did like I really wanted to
be somebody I was actually proud of you
know I wanted if somebody say you know
who inspires you or who's your hero who
you look up to I wanted to be able to
look I mean I say me and this thing is
walk it just called to me I think a lot
of people watching know what it's like
to have something that you know you're
supposed to do you're called to it
you're pulled towards it and most of us
think of some sort of reason why we
can't do it or a reason why we're gonna
do it later and my contention is you
know 95% of those reasons are actually
excuses and I made excuses for about
five years and then I realized hey man
you know you're gonna die one day either
gonna do this walk before then or not
you're 31 year old guy who has a great
list of accomplishments already at this
age not to get too deep and turn this
into maybe a therapy session but why did
why did you feel like this walk was
necessary for you to say that you've
accomplished something or that you
you've you're proud of what you've been
able to accomplish it's not that I felt
I had no accomplishments before them not
or that I'm not proud of any of those
accomplishments you know Grammy
nomination or you know popular songs or
you know all my albums I'm very proud of
I put a lot of hard work into those but
it just had a feeling an inkling that
there was more inside me and I think a
lot of people know what it's like to
feel like hey man I just got more to
offer and not really know what to do
with it
so I had this inkling you know there's
there's a little more in me let me see
if I could pull this this thing off and
I went out there and I found out I was
actually wrong there's a lot more of me
and so now my job is to just figure out
you know how to keep exploring that you
know and I always say keep going namely
new mixtape keep going and that was our
motto out there because you know you you
get to Kansas that's a big
accomplishment but now you gotta get
Colorado
keep going you know certainly if you
start in New Jersey as you did and you
know you got a New Jersey ID over there
and my sound guy Mike Dell to fill my
apartment my audio executive executive
he'd any spins he spend some tunes on
Friday nights so he always loves having
musicians on yourself yeah Asbury Park
New Jersey's where you started is at a
Springsteen inspiration yeah I was
looking at you know these places on the
East Coast where I could possibly start
the most important thing was you know my
walk actually not to nitpick you but it
wasn't New Jersey Callie was ocean to
ocean okay and so it was important for
me to be able to start with my feet in
the water now some places like New York
City man you can't really you can't
really put your feet in the water for
that sort of thing looking for a place
where I could get in the water and I was
looking at all these cities on the map I
recognized any of them except for Asbury
Park because uh because of the boss you
know curser yeah like the boss
okay so he wasn't in town when you when
you started I was trying to get some I
was posting like hey if anyone knows
Bruce Springsteen time to come walk with
me he never came but uh
I was worth the try but it's still a
great spot to start it was clear I know
I read his book you know he did his
autobiography and I recognized a lot of
the little cities freehold and stuff
from his book so it was kind of cool
mike posner here on the Rich Eisen show
the Gama the grammy-nominated singer
songwriter completed a walk across
America and so look Bruce might not have
seen your tweet or your Instagram feed
but millions of people did and you went
across who who did you meet I mean what
did you end up meeting on this trip that
made it even more significant I'm
Americans and especially at the
beginning you see a lot of the
Revolutionary War monuments you see a
lot of the old graveyards I'm talking
about graveyards where the some
tombstones you came to see the the
writing anymore just a little stones
because they've sunk so far and you feel
a lot of pride meeting these very kind
people who don't know who I am but
they're pulling their car over to make
sure I don't need a ride or make sure I
have water and I felt a lot of pride to
be American and meeting people like that
and Illinois and Indiana and then I kept
walking you know I kept walking across
the Rocky Mountains across Colorado
I eventually walked across the Navajo
Nation I walked across an Arizona it
actually spans four states and I met
people like Al Largo or Alex which
escuchar Skiba gay who explained me come
what's going on on their reservation you
know how their waters poisoned because
of a mine a uranium mine that our
countries put there and I felt actually
shame and for me you know doing this
walk being American is feeling pride and
shame at the same time and when you
walked were you walking on just
thoroughfares the streets or highways
were you literally walking on the side
of an interstate at some point good
question um it's illegal to walk on
interstate so I try to break as few laws
as posture on the right
there was one time I got permission from
Edison California from CHP to do like a
four mile stretch in on the interstate
but other than that I was mostly you
only like US highways or state highways
and then a lot of times I get kind of
lost in back roads and into the woods
and national parks that kind of thing
but definitely a lot of walking on
highways the walk across America is that
there's an Appalachian Trail and PCT
dozers beautiful trails if you can walk
across you're gonna basically almost get
hit by a car every day it could be very
careful right and where'd you lay your
head did you did you stay in any hotel
vehicle so I had a buddy with me and he
would go ahead of me basically eight
miles right catch up and usually we was
sleeping that they were the more
interesting parts you know the the Rocky
Mountains the Mavi desert things like
that it couldn't drive there as - the
roads weren't in good enough condition
so I'd sleep in the tent on those parts
those are the best parts what you'd
carry on your back we would have we
would have like like a Land Cruiser kind
of we switch vehicles so I oh I didn't
backpack now I'd like to be clear about
that walk supported because our people
out there right now walking unsupported
mm-hmm who are more amazing than me they
they put it all on their back mike
posner here on the Rich Eisen show at
Mike Posner is how people followed this
on Twitter and on Instagram then you get
to the to Colorado and you met up with a
rattlesnake and this is what definitely
went most viral on social media as you
were going through this bit by
rattlesnake yeah what I mean did you see
it did you not did you hear it I mean no
basically the only time you really get
bit by a rattlesnake is if you surprise
their sneak up on it and that's what I
unfortunately did I never saw it and so
what you felt it I felt a bite on my leg
you know honestly wasn't any it wasn't
more painful in the pain I was feeling
my feet at the time but my thought my my
brain went you just got bit I wonder
what bit bit me and then right after I
had that thought I heard
Shh and I went man I know it that noise
he could probably finish that noise
within with a nightie so then did you
call what did you do I mean you had a
cell phone on your imagine right so we
were in the middle of nowhere so
basically I was 30 miles from the last
town about 60 from the next town and
damn Mike we didn't have any service
there was a gentleman walking with me
that day who came he heard about the
journeys came out wanted to walk with me
and he ran to the road a little bit
right and he was able to get a bar
service called 911 and the dispatch lady
was speaking to me she said look you
know we're sending two ambulances to you
in the helicopter whatever gets there
first get in there and I said you know
yeah at first I just felt like you know
I got stung by a strong B but then about
five minutes later that that poison
started go through me how does that feel
it felt like the remember the Looney
Tunes at the end that the circle gets
smaller and smaller and they say that's
all folks right like that with my my
consciousness was just getting it was
black coming in closing in on me and
that's not realize hey man you didn't
you didn't get stung by a bee me and I
asked her on the phone I said you know
am I gonna survive and she said I'm not
sure sir so you'll come to find out most
people get bit by snakes in America they
get the help they need and they survive
and when you're not in the mood so far
away from from from help so when what
did get first ambulance ambulance to a
hospital okay basically pump me up with
the antivenin and then the doctor came
in and say hey look man I think you're
gonna need more and we gave all of ours
to you or medicine so then they put me
in the chopper took me to another
hospital and I was kind of fun actually
okay I mean wow
so and we saw that you were rehabbing it
took you five days to get back into V
and you started walking
it took me five days to get a hospital
you know so the first time I couldn't
even walk to the bathroom you know you
go for 24
miles a day to zero and then they gave
me a walker they taught me how to use
that and eventually I got discharged I
went home to Michigan and that's just
start you know basically I could one day
walk to the bathroom in the kitchen then
I would walk to my neighbors and down
the street and just built it back up to
eventually got up to around thirty miles
a day but yeah I was out for three weeks
total so then why did you did you give
any consideration to not continuing your
walk and finish yeah no I when I started
this thing you know I told the public
I'm gonna walk across America but that's
not what I said to myself what I said to
myself was I'm gonna walk across America
no matter what and I think you know as
you well know anything worthwhile in
life is gonna be hard and things are
gonna go wrong on the on the journey
towards it so I had already visualized
myself succeeding yes but I actually
also visualized myself going through
really hard times I visualized myself
breaking my leg what you're gonna do and
I knew I used to tell my friends hey if
I break my leg I'll go back to that spot
after I'm healed and I'll finish my walk
I'm walking no matter what and so when
things did go wrong I got bit by a snake
I'm in the hospital I didn't have to I
don't have to negotiate with myself I
have to rethink hey maybe it's not meant
to be which is really code for I'm
giving up I just knew I was walking no
matter what and so once I healed I was
gonna go back to that spot where I got
bit and I was gonna keep going you did
so you went back to that spot X exact
spot it was terrible I was very scared I
didn't want to go back there but it was
important for me do you know for my walk
to have integrity to to you know have no
breaks in the in my walk so you went
back to that spot yeah and then you
finished that's right what was it like
for you when you reached Venice
California and you put your feet in the
Pacific Ocean
oh man that's one of the best moments of
my life and it was so special because
they were all the
all people with many of the people I
really love that love me they were there
and I just felt like I had tapped in a
part of myself I didn't really know was
there or I had a intuition there was
there but I found I was really there and
I didn't know I didn't feel done it felt
good but I also just felt more excited
that hey man if you could do this what
else could you do and now when I look at
life's buffet it's a lot more choices
there you know so that's that's I think
what felt so good about it then what did
you learn from it shoot I learned a lot
of things I think we talked about some
of them already one you any contract you
set yourself gotta have a no matter what
clause in it I learned that you know
when you go through real pain you know
it hurts to walk across America every
day that's where you find real strength
and most of us myself you know spent
probably the first 30 years of my life
trying to make it as comfortable as
possible and hey you know all like the
the peace of mind the sense of security
and myself that was on the other side of
a lot of pain and suffering and and
discomfort and so I learned not to be so
afraid of pain discover a lot of us okay
so we want to be comfortable timing
before we know it we're living a very
small life and I learned there's a lot
is a lot outside of that sandbox well
man congratulations on on what you
learned about yourself and you go
through it you you hit that that fork in
the road with the rattlesnake and you
get back out there and you complete your
walk across America Congrats on your new
album keep going and then the song
nothing is wrong Anke you are welcome
and I appreciate you coming on here to
give the exclusive to the Rich Eisen
show Mike Posner's even got across South
America neck
no no but so uh I got some ideas what is
your next challenge do you have one I
got some ideas but nothing no plans yet
no so I don't want to say I'm not gonna
say something less I'm sure I'm gonna do
it okay you know Europe I'm not gonna
say so okay congratulations brother hey
thanks go blue ah yes
I appreciate that yeah your your
Michigander correct I'm Michigander and
you know I went to Duke University I
like that blue tube I like both those
blues okay my dad went to mission you
know what you are somebody that I can't
even dispute that cuz you know I'm and
and what you've just told me about what
you've learned and about how divided our
country might be but yet it's all
together normally hearing somebody said
I like Michigan and Duke would be very
strange for me but I'm gonna accept it
from you mike posner get it because I
you have taught me the better of my ways
this conversation at Mike Posner on both
Twitter and Instagram to follow more
from this man we are back to learn
what's going on in the NFL trade
deadline world while we had this great
conversation that's next in the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app